leute ich bin jetzt fertig alle schluss
dass ich wurde den kompliziertesten
techniken und alt und dieses gift
geschenk ist nun das neue abc zum video
für euch
32 ein herzlicher würde was heute ein
ganz besonderes video wird der die leute
ihr habt dem titel und dem fan page
angesehen meine freundin wird mich heute
schminken das ist eine sache die sie
sich schon sehr lange gewünscht hat ich
habe gesagt okay auch wenn du unbedingt
dass ich es zumindest für ein video
verwerten kann deswegen sitzt heute hier
sind geschminkten und ganz wichtig aber
doch vorrat von leute sie hat sich ein
bisschen gedanken gemacht ob ihr als
meine zuschauer vielleicht ein bisschen
gemein oder kritisch zu sein werdet
deswegen seit zu lieb seit märz wieder
in den kommentaren und ja und ganz
wichtig leute mein bruder max hat ist
teil von der richtig richtig geilen
kooperation mit amazon prime video zum
serienstart von der serie lz
informationen dazu habe ich euch in
diesem video versteckt also bleibt
unbedingt bis zum ende dran plätze im
video was ist das jetzt gerade einfach
das wollte sie wollte dass ich etwas
pinks anti so zum harald wollen ja so
kann kannst mit schminken aber ich muss
jetzt nicht gleich irgendwie okay ganz
seltsame frau bereit
ich habe letztens auch von lara fake
lashes angeklebt bekommen und sarah
wohnt in der gegend wo auch ein bisschen
ja verschiedene gemischtes klientel
unterwegs und dann sind wir einfach
nachts raus und ich hatte fake lashes
haben wir sind an so einer gruppe von 20
breiten typen vorbei gelaufen und ich
hatte so eine fake lashes dann guck mal
ganz gut sollte ich das hier ist
übrigens das arsenal was hier auch
gefahren wurde an schminke leute also
wirklich geisteskrank ist wirklich also
du willst er wisse auch nicht wie lange
ich bin aktuell bist du auf jeden fall
der vampir ich unterwegs bin gleich
schon bekannten vielleicht muss ich kurz
nach die chance dass außer dem was sie
gerne antreten
apple warten warum steht darum links
eigentlich werbung
ich glaube wir haben die meldung ich
habe ja keine mehr haben am ehrenmal
trifft meldung kommt ist nicht die heute
das laufende programme für eine
eilmeldung zu dieser stunde erreicht uns
die nachricht dass für zuschauer des
kanals sp ist die möglichkeit gibt
preise im wert von über 500 euro zu
gewinnen übereinstimmenden meldungen
zufolge handelt es sich hierbei um eine
kooperation mit amazon prime video
anlässlich des starts der serie lz
verschiedenen nachrichtendienste melden
zusätzlich dass der youtuber krankhafter
an dieser kooperation ebenfalls mit
wir werden zur aktuellen stunde
informierte dass die serie lz am 18
dezember auf amazon prime video
verfügbar ist die serie spielt im
mittelalter und erzählt die
lebensgeschichte des gleichnamigen
spanischen nationalhelden und ich kann
ihnen an dieser stelle mitteilen dass
ich persönlich sehr viel spaß gehabt
habe die ersten folge dieser serie
schauen zu können aber wir sind sie sind
wir nicht ins kino oder nein ich bin es
okay er ist er will damit werden sind
die beiden youtube asp und kran kräfte
auf dem amazon kleinen video kanal in
einer challenge gegeneinander angetreten
und haben preise erspielt die ihre
jeweiligen community nun gewinnen können
um an diesem gewinnspiel teilzunehmen
und besagte preise gewinnen zu können
müssen sie auf den amazon prime
videokanal ihn auf das video der beiden
youtuber escape krankhafter und einen
kommentar hinterlassen mit dem inhalt
fzs kay und zusätzlich in den
kommentaren reinschreiben wie viele
produkte sich in der box vom youtuber
escape befanden sinnliche
teilnahmebedingungen sind in der infobox
des videos auf dem amazon prime
videokanal verlinkt ich fordere sie an
dieser stelle also dringlich und von
ganzem herzen auf besagtes video auf dem
amazon prime videokanal zuschauen und
gleichermaßen die serie lz abzuchecken
an dieser stelle auch immer die hinweise
dass am ende dieses videos in der
sogenannten and card besagt das video
auf dem meer sondern beim videokanal
verlinkt es ebenso wie in der infobox
von diesem video meine damen und herren
fabi ford mit unseren regulären programm
machen
da steht kleber drauf
es ist ein jammer you look kein of
twilight -vampire also ich muss sagen
der look hier nimmt diesen milchig
verschwommenen hintergrund das ist schon
die youtube channel also ich finde
erstmal ist betont die augenbrauen schon
sehr oder besser es wird eine frau
ich wurde einmal schon so ein bisschen
von sony geschmeckt hat es noch nie lux
vor ein paar jahren ich sage ich das ist
man denkt sich sehr lustig wir machen
was man die schuhe geschenkt nicht mal
dann hat man sieht gar nichts von der
veränderung während die stadt findet am
ende schaut mal in den spiegel und denkt
sich pro jahr
[Musik]
all das braucht eine eigene basis ist
das nennen wir das so 31 bürsten hast
normal hat ja das ist bei der geburt in
münchen einen dort müssten wenn die
einen verlieren dann werden die
grenzländer das ist dass hier was heißt
hier dieses ding da du dummer
menschenaffe gib mir essen also bisher
ist die veränderung noch noch sehr ich
würde sagen geht danach sie wirklich aus
hass 1 11 1 prozent
das macht mit lashes wenn es der
verdiener schwinden könnte
den dass die braten muss übrigens zac
was du dir jetzt ebenso eine frage wieso
eine bratwurst und ein bisschen dann
braucht es auch bei uns gott das ist
wirklich so krank wie viele produkte
einzelne produkte braucht man für so
make ups hat bekomme jetzt mal 36 oder
so stellt das ist wirklich alles krank
war hätte diese momente wo man sich
manchmal so denkt so warum bedeutet wo
es heißt brot eigentlich brot so was
habe ich zum beispiel wenn ich mir denke
da einfach alle frauen in deutschland
nicht alle aber viele sachen einfach
jeden morgen auf dem schminken sie
irgendwie einer dreiviertelstunde oder
stunden dann ist mir egal wie krank ich
könnte nicht leben wenn ich es jetzt
machen willst du wirklich hatte sohn und
trank realisation gestern wir haben
sowie den stopp von so klassen wählen in
der serie und ich sagte mir so wie
vielen weg wohl sonne sonne welle nein
dachte okay also 1000 liter sind ja ne
tonnen ja und dann darfst du okay gibt
wie packt man auf eine perspektive
wie viel tausend liter sind und dann
dachte mir sehr okay 1 1 kubikmeter
wasser halten und dann dachten so ja wie
vor passt ein kubikmeter wasser rein in
so eine regentonne daher kommt bestimmt
das mag eine tonne kommt wie hole ich
mir hundert kurzen die täler ab das sind
die augen stand jetzt wie fühlst du dich
so sehr vermisst du schon bist du ein
gemachter mann ich könnte ich bin
misstrauisch und aber am ende werde ich
selbst habe ich nicht viel geschaut so
gespannt updates reaktionen im büro von
max
wenn er zwischendurch nicht reinschauen
sollte er wird flüchten wenn nämlich
gleichzeitig 1000 prozent ja also bisher
sieht es ein bisschen nach einer
schlaflosen nacht mit ein bisschen
glitzer aus da ist auch meistens klare
sachen besser machen als erstes
wimperntusche
so sieht also das endprodukt aus augen
zu ok sehr verzieht jan ist schon
ausgerastet
wer hat was du drauf gesagt ich komme
hier nie so schön gesehen eigentlich was
kommt als nächstes
als nächstes kommen fake lashes ist das
normal
wie fühlt sich so auch frauen wie die
somit faktisch sind club gehen also man
hat so teilen der ozeane
sie gehört zu weit niedriger ist noch
relativ natürlich lächelt mir sicher
bist darfst du ein großer unterschied
foundation in 321 o jedes mal wenn ich
die sehe ich ein sehr erfreulich dass es
gar nichts gutes für nicht bedeuten dass
kann nichts gutes bedeuten jetzt kommt
auch der concealer drauf seite weißt du
sagt nein
irgendwas wird konzipiert und was wird
verdeckt bedenkt ja dann letztlich
informiert dass wir jetzt gleich
irgendwas machen was wie heißt country
konnten touring was was macht man da wir
konkurrieren habe ich noch nicht genug
kultur im gesicht nein das meine gene
gehalt ist okay wenn das vielleicht
einen markanten kiefern oder so
scheinbar nicht es war konkurriert
werden
ach so ja stimmt will zuhören bringt ja
ich möchte ich weiter mache das ganze 18
23 menschen ok 3 2 1
als nächstes kommt platz habe ich gehört
dass ich weiter und lag damit wir da
eine kontur sehen können belastet mich
zur seite drehen
sie hat mein gesicht konnte das hat mir
die ganze zeit gefährdet ich bin so froh
dass ja geschmückt natürlich klatsche
ich halte es runter geht aber im echten
leben sieht man es auf jeden fall sehr
schön konturiert ja eigentlich aber
gesicht kultur also meine damen und
herren gehen wir uns die blas und der
highlighter du bist ja schon ein
bisschen müde vom 321
mit einem großen schrecken habe ich
erfahren dass jetzt lipliner lippenstift
und lipgloss drauf los
das was du recht das nichts für mich ist
aber okay das machen wir jetzt brauchen
wir ein kritischer beäugt und dann gibt
es keinen reveal okay für euch jetzt
sofort wird ja ich will jetzt fertig
geschminkt ich ahne schlimmstes wurde
die kompliziertesten techniken und
produkten die es gibt geschenke an wird
das neue team zum menü für euch 32 ich
sagte ich sage euch sagen wie es sein
wird ich habe den spielern leben vorbei
jetzt übrigens auch unser tisch gerade
kein wunder dass er plötzlich auf aber
jetzt ist er wieder den spiegel also
fragte ich nicht warum man sich an der
wand etwas zu den spiegel vor wie zum
spiegel gehen und sie passen sich selbst
sieht muss dave jetzt einmal ganz kurz
beeindruckt zum besten geben
[Musik]
dies war hofft wettringen sie haben
währen wird erfüllt sie wollte mich
schminken
ich war so jaffé mach und dann mag
zumindest ein video so ok und jenny hat
feierabend ja dann bitte ich dich bis zu
25 leute also ich finde ich finde das
geht überhaupt nicht leute dieses videos
eine lektion wenn man in einer beziehung
ist mit allen menschen egal welchen
beziehung muss man diesen menschen
manchmal auch wünsche erfüllen diesen
grund habe ich jetzt hier mit erfüllt
und ich habe mir was ich habe 100 leute
hätte soldo seine leute zeigt wie gesagt
es sind abteile serie auf mit der serie
nicht so ausgiebig jetzt gerade ist
wirklich da reinzuschauen gesagt hat wie
die ente auch für das gewinnspiel leute
ich wünsche euch viel viel erfolg und
viel glück dabei und ja bis zum nächsten
video